good afternoon it's a pleasure to
welcome all of you to this columbia
world leaders forum event my name is
Michel Gerard I am a professor at
Columbia Law School and director of the
Center for climate change law we're
honored to be joined today by the
President of the Republic of the
Marshall Islands
Christopher J Luke president Loic
welcome to Columbia and we thank you for
being here today we also want to welcome
senator Tony de Broome Minister in
assistance to the President and several
other leading officials from the
Republic of the Marshall Islands who are
also with us today
this event is co-sponsored by the
Columbia Earth Institute which functions
as an interdisciplinary hub bringing
together engineers economists legal
scholars social political and physical
scientists and more than 200 research
scientists from the lamont-doherty Earth
Observatory the world leaders forum who
is founded in 2003 by our University
President Lee Bollinger to support
robust dialogue and the most pressing
issues facing the global economy for 10
years it has allowed our students
faculty and staff to engage directly
with the men and women who are
addressing the major challenges of the
21st century by making it possible for
the Columbia community to enter into a
structured dialogue with foreign heads
of state the world leaders forum has
become a leading example of the open
debate and insistence on considering
opposing viewpoints that define our
academic community along with the
network of Columbia global centers and
our Committee on global thought the
world leaders forum plays an essential
role in making Columbia a truly global
University the Republic of the Marshall
Islands once a UN Trust Territory
administered by the United States became
a sovereign nation in 1986 it has a
population of roughly 55,000 people with
twenty-nine eight halls and five
Islands some 2,400 miles west of Hawaii
just north of the equator almost the
entire country is only about two meters
above sea level
today's sea level that makes it one of
the nation's most threatened by the
rising seas but this is not the first
time that the outside world has
dangerously intruded on this peaceful
Micronesia nation during World War two
it was the scene of major naval battles
and from 1946 through 1958 the United
States detonated a total of 67 nuclear
weapons over the Marshall Islands a
tall's bikini and noe tok leaving a toll
of human and environmental damage that
very much persists to this day nearly
four years ago the government of the
Marshall Islands approached the center
for climate change law here for help in
addressing the numerous unprecedented
legal questions that arise when a nation
is threatened with submersion we've been
working with them ever since and I've
had the honor of visiting them twice
most recently earlier this month for the
44th Pacific Islands Forum which the
president will be discussing president
Loic attended Marshall Islands High
School and then traveled to the United
States to study at Hawaii's Pacific
white Pacific College and then at
Gonzaga University Law School in Spokane
Washington he was first elected to the
national parliament in 1985 and served
as Minister of Justice Minister of
Social Services and Minister of
Education please join me in welcoming
president Christopher J law jack
excellencies professors faculty students
ladies and gentleman first let me say
thank you very much
to prepare the track for his kind
introduction and to Colombia in which
they for hosting me today allow me also
to take this opportunity to thank the
professor and the Columbia Law School
for the tireless work you have done and
continue to do so with the Marshall
Islands the conference you co-hosted
here with the Marshall Islands
government in 2011 to look at the legal
implications of sea-level rise and our
other climate impacts of small island
countries open many eyes and minds to
the very real challenges that lie ahead
many around the world know little of my
home the Marshall Islands it is a
beautiful country made up of more than a
thousand individual islands in 24
low-lying coral atolls rings in the
Northern Pacific such mm some miles
southwest of Hawaii we are a proud
nation but we also feed great challenges
in addressing core social and economic
development goals basic health education
private and private sector growth among
others when you apply over our at all
rings in an airplane
the site is protecting in its beauty at
the same time it turns upon you our
honourable our Ethel home really is it
takes your breath away there are only
four fully island at all nations in the
world apart from the Maldives in the
Indian Ocean
the other three live in the Pacific
kilowatts Tuvalu and the Marshall
Islands we lie at an average of about
two meters or six feet above sea level
with these unique qualities we face a
dual threat from climate change not only
do we face rising temperatures causing
oceans to expand and melting polar ice
but we are also seeing ocean change as
emission under the water eating away at
the coral beneath our our feet report
after international report including a
new high PPC report to this week
conclude that by the end of the century
we are on track for four degrees Celsius
or more of global warming our local tied
cases so rapidly increasing sea level
rise inches are becoming feet I am not
scientific expert but I can tell you
what I see with my own eyes the seawall
protecting our Airport now has sent
backs instead of rock walls while
islands always change the event of our
local communities she now saw water
coming into our drinking water
coastal erosion in Ireland's both remote
and developed things that our elders did
not witness this is not the first time
Marshallese people have fished typical
threats after World War Two the Marshall
Islands and tore 67 nuclear tests
including the proper shot that was 1,000
times more powerful than the bomb that
was dropped on Hiroshima this test not
only destroyed lives but LED islands and
inevitable war generations and turn
local communities away from their
homeland a situation which still remains
poor modulus in a ways in ways that the
English language can as fully cannot
fully convey our island is we are it is
nature's our culture but our personal
identity in 1954 and 1956 we petitioned
the United Nations to stop nuclear
testing we one of the harm we were met
with empty sympathies
unlike the Cold War the global nuclear
risk today is very different but it was
not without every burden very heavy
burden carried by modulus people the
Marshall Islands must never again become
the global cut the collateral damage of
international in action again today the
international community is still not
listening in the long term the 60,000
modulus people of my country stand to
lose our homes our livelihoods our
history our security in our culture I
cannot put it any more snugly than that
these are the very same risk police
reached by the Marshall Islands in our
island are the small islands over 25
visible if only the world as lesson 10
says because the problem is creeping
upon us in spines does not make it any
less compelling or any less urgent
this is a new type of emergency lights
of which the world has yet to see for
which the world lacks an adequate
respond for some climate change is an
important policy issue but one among
many and it is little more than a
distant threat for us in the Marshall
Island
climate change has already arrived in
May this year my government was forced
to declare a state of disaster after a
prolonged and unprecedented drought
across our northern atolls left many of
our people with barely enough food and
water to survive this anger and this is
quickly settled and we call for
international help when it arrived we
were hit immediately by king tide rising
seas that topped the seawall in our
capital city module forcing the closure
of our Airport and flooding many homes
including my own backyard to climate
disaster in two months this is the us
new reality of climate change and after
last year's superstorm
it seems New Yorkers are starting to
feel the same way too everything is
experience that is why I'm here
bringing our message to the world
time is up we are now or we fail while
the Marshall Islands did not invite nor
did we expect the looming climate crisis
the true measure of our people is how
its respond to adversity there is no
more potent respond than leadership not
in words but in action not in promises
but in commitments not in delay but in
doing what is right and doing it now
like Pacific neighbors we are working
hard to win ourselves of the expensive
and polluting fossil fuels that have
long power communities when we finalize
our national energy plan in 209 we found
that more than 90 percent of our energy
was generated from expensive imported
fossil fuel this was clearly a creep
economic threat to our national economy
like others in the Pacific we decided to
take a new path we look for ways to
quickly enhance the contribution of
renewable energy fast forward to today
we have installed solar panels across
our face outer islands cities our hope
and my intention that every household
every school
every clinic and every dispensaries in
the outer island will have been
completed completely powered by the
clean and natural energy of the Sun we
will complete this next year and today
we have already achieved 95% coverage
when you consider this Islands a stress
across a million square miles of ocean
you realize that this is an enormous
achievement and one of which we are very
proud we are leading by example others
in the Pacific are now taking a similar
approach with Kiribati Tuvalu a Nui or
trying to have 100% renewable energy by
2020 our simple message to the bigger
country is this if we can do it so can
you
this commitment to heck extend not only
to reducing emissions but also preparing
our local communities to better
withstand some level of climate impacts
now and those to come the government
will attempt to and reduce the stretch
must go pee on people policies and into
our local communities with visible
physicals results to protect our water
source national areas and our human
shielding this is not about doing but we
can passively wait for solution from
others
ultimately we can solve the climate
crisis on our own if we are to ensure
the survival of my country in human life
as we know it
we must urgently unleash a global global
movement what we call a new wave of
climate leadership climate change is
addressed not just through distant Union
resolutions but with leadership action
and momentum world leaders are failing
intervening a new level of direct
political dialogue which goes beyond the
senseless beginning of negotiators in
fact the international community should
not negotiate climate change but world
leaders much better collaborate to
address climate risk with meaningful
results after the 2009 Copenhagen talks
collapse the Marshall Island decided
that waiting for a new global agreement
to curb emission was too big a risk and
that we need to take matters into our
own hands
internationally we are seeking to frame
a new climate diplomacy meaning that we
have made climate change a central
pillar of our foreign policy and
committed to raise it wherever and
whenever we can but merely raising it is
not enough
again leadership by example is key
rather than waving our hands in distress
we put up our end last year to host this
year paw report meeting of the Pacific
Islands Forum leaders which includes the
heads of state and government from the
14 Pacific Island countries plus
Australia and New Zealand with 60
percent of global greenhouse gas
emission coming from the Pacific Rim we
chose an action-oriented team for the
meeting and I quote marshalling the
Pacific respond to the climate challenge
and code and that's exactly what we set
out to do our Pacific friends descended
upon national in the first week of
September and we were joined quickly by
our deployment for forum dialogue
partners from the region and Beyond
including the world's two biggest images
the United States and China as well as
India Japan Republic of South Korea and
the European Union and several of its
member states to focus our efforts we
proposed the material declaration for
climate leadership as the signature
outcome from the meeting many were
nervous we were trying to recreate
international climate negotiations in a
parallel process but all worked out
quickly that exactly the opposite was
true
the declaration is fresh for looking and
forceful I encourage you to take a look
it opens with the bull line climate
change as a right it recognized the
leadership role of the Pacific Islands
in accelerating global efforts to
transition to renewable energy and calls
on other others to commit to become
climate leaders by listing specific
commitments to contribute more than
previous efforts to urgently reduce
greenhouse gas pollution but simply in
his most basic terms it is a technology
to do more I am proud to say that the
Metro declaration was unanimously
adopted by the forum members and as we
see a strong chorus of support from our
forum dialogue partners importantly the
United States Safety intend to support
the declaration and duet for the first
time internationally President Obama's
new climate action plan to the list of
commitments attached to the declaration
the U in the UK are preparing to submit
commitments and others including the
Philippines Malaysia Thailand Republic
of South Korea Indonesia and France also
showing join a long list of supporters
who intend to step forward soon with
their own commitments
it is also important to remember that
the declaration is the first text I was
kind to encourage commitments from both
governments as well as non-state actors
including cities companies and civil
society organizations we all need to act
and ever share responsibility to do so
for example the state of Hawaii is now
preparing to sign up to the declaration
with its emphasis clean energy program
and we hoped that others such as New
York City will - so - given that Mayor
Bloomberg has been a passionate advocate
for climate action this week I'm in New
York to take forward the work we began
in national last month on Sunday I met
with the UN Secretary General Ban
ki-moon and I will meet him again on
Friday
this time alongside my fellow Pacific
leaders as we agreed at the Forum
meeting we will present the Metro tech
law region to the secretary-general as a
contribution to his own efforts to spark
a new wave of climate leadership and
build momentum for his climate change
summit in September 2014 and the
deadline for the inking have a new
international agreement in France in
2015 this declaration does not by any
means solve the global crisis but it
holds the hope
of new answers at a time when all
politics have failed
thankfully the union secretary-general
understands says how important the fight
against climate changes
this past February he announced that
climate change is one of his two main
political priorities for this year
alongside Syria could there be a clear
expression of the tire threat climate
change poses to the world in the year
ahead a chairs of the Pacific Islands
Forum my absolute priority will be to
fight for a shape climate future for my
people the Pacific region and indeed the
entire world we must seize this moment
and we Tara gate ourselves to ensuring
that a new wave of climate leadership
takes hold while countries like mine
will be the first to go we are only the
front line no country is immune we must
all declare our sincere and heartfelt
commitment to take responsibility every
one of us government citizen and right
to win this war this is a war for
nothing less than the future of humanity
it will take every one of us Kemal Tata
thank you very much
thank you very much mr. president we
would now like to invite questions I
would ask people who are interested in
asking questions to line up behind the
two microphones that are in the aisle
there and when you ask a question please
also indicate your name and what school
within Columbia University you are
affiliated with and as people think
about their questions let me first pose
one if I may and and and to say that as
I indicated we are also joined by
Senator Tony Tony de broom who is
Minister and assistance to the president
mr. president has there been sought
given to the possibility of relocating
some of the population of the Marshall
Islands to other countries that are not
as endangered by sea level is that
something that's under consideration
no I the majority of the modulus people
believe that it doesn't matter if if the
islands are submerged they they will go
with the IRAs so this is also my my
belief and nobody want to leave the
islands and because of climate change
that's why we're trying everything
within our power and means to bring
about change
you're gonna stay regardless
I just did it that many times that if
water comes it comes senator which like
to add a few words Thank You professor
just just to add on to the president's
response we have labored with this issue
for some time the Marshall Islands are
not strangers to displacement we have
communities within our own country now
that have been displaced from their
homelands as a result of World War two
and as a result of the testing program
some of our homelands will not be
inhabitable for the next four thousand
years but the prospect of our plan the
displacement of communities and people
is repugnant to Island people it is also
a in a way in the way the president is
is expressing it to our constituencies
is an admittance of defeat before we are
actually defeated we still are confident
that there are ways that we can prevent
this necessity from happening our
neighbors to the south for example
Cuba's AI has already received funds
from the international community to
begin to invest in a community to which
they will send people from the Gilberts
Cuba's in Fiji the same kind of
discussion has been has been had in our
part of the world but we are staring
standing fast in our view that first we
must we must stop climate change from
doing this I was
in fact our family since before we think
about actual displacement of populations
but it is prudent for leaders to keep
this in mind it is a matter of survival
maybe we'll build us as fast as the tide
comes up but to move us from our home is
tantamount to asking as the eliminated
society from the face of the earth
talking about elimination of tradition
of language of a way of life and that is
really something very impossible to
consider at this point thank you sir
once again if people have questions I'd
ask them to go to the microphone and I
think I see a question if you could
identify yourself and what school you're
associated with hi I'm Eric Ward sir I'm
part of the international programs at
the law school I was interested in
hearing perhaps a little bit more about
the effects of the of the history of the
bombing and what more specifically were
the environmental effects and what types
of redress is your country seeking as a
result of that as part of the settlement
under the compact of free association
which governs the relationship between
the United States and the Marshalls
there was a fund set up to provide
compensation for physical injury and
property damage the fund was set up at
150 million dollars in 1986 based on
the United States own estimate as to
what those damages or will amount to in
terms of money as it is turned out we
have not been able to compensate in full
any of the claimants for physical injury
so this day we have just barely touched
some of the land damages claims but for
the most part those are adjudicated but
not faith and the amount is closer to
four billion than hundred and fifty
million those those amounts are based on
the United States own formula for
deciding how much to pay for certain
anomalies certain sicknesses as well as
land damage for calculated on a
production basis minister would you like
to spend a minute just describing there
mr. president the nuclear claims
tribunal and what it did it how it
operated so to administer this fund the
150 million dollars a nuclear tribunal
was established again by agreement with
the United States which allowed for
people to file claims and the
three-member tribunal would adjudicate
these claims establishing a an award for
either physical injury or for land
damages physical injuries were put up as
a priority for those conversations but
as I said today we have not been able to
fully compensate for those for those
physical injuries and litigation has
been brought by various groups in the
Marshall Islands against the United
States government to seek compensation
but so far all of that litigation has
been
dismissed by the courts of the United
States as outside of their jurisdiction
my name is Eric L Bay from the School of
Engineering mr. president thank you very
much for coming to us today
I had a question concerning the recent
treaty you were describing that has been
signed in unfortunately I have not
gotten around to reading it yet though I
most certainly will with your mention of
it so thank you
but could you mention what you think the
most critical points of action in the
treaty are it is called a magical
declaration and you can access it at
magical declaration dot-org actually you
can sign onto it
what did what the declaration does is it
it first of all it recognizes that
efforts so far at addressing climate
change impacts or the threats of climate
change have fallen quite short of
expectations of the of the most
vulnerable countries and the rest of the
world that we have we talk about it a
lot we understand it a lot the science
is in there is really no action being
taken secondly it allows for member
countries of the forum so we commit to
their own ambitions that declaration of
emissions ambitions so that if anyone
wants to do a little bit more than had
been expected they can also add on it's
a it's a living dynamic document that
that is open for for add-on of ambitious
as time goes by thirdly it is not
limited to through governmental
jurisdictions it is open to two states
for example this week we expect to
announce tomorrow or Friday that the
state of Hawaii has signed on as the
Hawaiian Islands and something that
miracles of miracles has been approved
by the United States State Department so
we take that as a good sign also it
allowed for example for the Secretary of
Interior to pledge the to list the Obama
plan for climate change as part of the
declaration now this morning the
president of the European Union
announced that a breakfast meeting that
the European Union is working to not
only Lisbon hopefully we can talk them
into listening more than and they have
actually forced to list it also opens up
for nongovernmental organizations
private sector to sign on to this
declaration of climate hope we have
already talked to for example the the
Outrigger hotel system of hoy which owns
properties all throughout the Pacific to
sign on as a private corporation the
Nature Conservancy was the first
engineer to sign on even while we were
still talking about the the declaration
in Majuro
it has gained a lot of support and
momentum for our we're very proud it was
sort of the crown of the wreath relay
the garland that you put on the forum in
Majuro to differentiate it from other
forums I truly find shade for my name is
Mia Dillon I'm a senior at Columbia
College thank you for coming to speak
with us today
I was reading that
Islands accepts a lot of foreign aid and
this is going to increase over the next
decade I was wondering what plans does
your government have to be more
sustainable and unchain yourself from
foreign development aid and assistance
in your climate change initiatives and
other development initiatives the
Marshall Islands receives a lot of
assistance from from various sources
including the United States however we
do not necessarily define the assistance
that we receive as a we provide for the
United States for example access to our
waters our lands and our our our skies
for defense and security purposes and
that has a price in the compact the
United States pledge to do certain
things and we pledge to give back
certain things so it's a trade off it is
not necessarily just helpless Pacific
natives sitting there waiting for people
to throw money at them but it is a way
of of failing something that we have for
something that we need there are people
were generally their countries will have
given generously to our development
programs for example we have solarized
our our island communities through the
assistance of the European Union France
Japan Taiwan and certain other donors it
also contributes one of our
contributions to a clean cleaner earth
the fact that we've been able to do this
in Islands that spread over a million
square miles is in itself I think a a
commendable kind of
but we do try our best to to increase
our trade we are members of the parties
to the Nauru agreement the eight
countries that make up that agreement
account for about 54 percent of the
world's raw tuna so then our likelihood
the tuna that you had last week was
probably from our part of the world
thank you my name is Richard Weinstein
I'm an attorney in New York and New
Jersey formerly with the Environmental
Protection Agency for about eight years
and I worked on a number of matters and
Superfund and this whole issue of global
warming reminds me of the immediate
concern of dealing with a problem that
was super fun which was the hazardous
waste dangers that to people and to
lands and the saturation of chemicals
and what was the solution was getting
money to solve the problem of not making
a piecemeal attack but actually going
there and spending whatever's needed to
remediate the problem and the parallel
seems to me to be here and I was
wondering are you familiar with the case
the Kivalina case which was brought in
the sunken in California in the Northern
District of California by an Indian
tribe or a actually Alaskan tribe that
is a sovereign nation in Alaska that
a----- suing all the fossil fuel
companies all the oil companies to try
to get money to deal with the problem
that they face which is also the problem
that the Marshall Islands face which is
one of your solutions is to abandon me
the settlement there and to leave the
the area that they've been in for time
immemorial was the word they use it
seems to me that a case against all
those those oil companies Exxon
he all the ones that are listed in the
Catalina cake Evelina case might be a
solution for the Marshall Islands and
maybe would bring more attention to them
and bring money which sounds like to me
could be a solution at least to start to
deal with things other than numerating
the greenhouse gas reductions and
solutions you came up with before which
you enumerated to actually get some on
the ground you know response from those
people who may be responsible the theory
is that these these oil companies
created all these fossil fuels that have
been burned and have been creating the
greenhouse gases that are causing the
heating of the atmosphere I think we
have the question there have been
discussions in the past about suing
agencies of the United States involved
in the testing for example all the
private contractors that did some of the
work out there when we when we settle
the the compact negotiations with the
United States there was a provision in
there called the espousal where as a
price for freedom lien honestly the
prices government from the new
government of the Marshall Islands
pledge to espouse all claims against the
United States you know and 150 million
dollars that was set aside to compensate
for the nuclear damages that has been a
an impediment to move forward with some
of the some of the cases that might look
that might look attractive to recover
damages however that provision also
contains a window which goes something
like this if in the future you discover
that there are change circumstances that
are different from what you knew in 1986
when the settlements may
then you may file a petition it changed
circumstance petition with the United
States Congress to to retail the issue
of compensation and the adequacy thereof
that has been done but there has been no
response from the United States that was
filed in 2000 so 13 years now we're
still trying to taking it back and
trying to rewrite it and revive it again
to see if we might be able to find ways
in that Avenue but there are there are
attempts there are efforts aren't going
to try and find ways to deal with this
massive problem of damages that needs to
be it's an open wound between the two
countries that need to be it needs to be
healed there there are people also
trying to help us just simply filing
action to compel the United States to
live up to its obligations that seems to
be on paper but not yet fair enough I
would just say that the Cuba leading
case which mr. Weinstein I mentioned
wasn't back brought that last December
it was dismissed by the United States
Court of Appeals for the Ninth Circuit
based on an earlier Supreme Court
decision holding that when Congress
enacted the Clean Air Act it gave
EPA the authority to regulate air
pollutants including greenhouse gas
emissions and therefore EPA had
exclusive charge over what to do about
greenhouse gases in the US and it was
not for the courts to set up the kinds
of rules that the plaintiffs in the
Cavallini case so on Yahoo I come from
coyotes my name is Lauda some blood I am
a student at the School of International
and public affairs and I had the good
fortune of living and working in the
Marshall Islands for two years prior to
coming to Columbia first on the island
up the ball and out
magic right here so I'm very happy to
see marshalese leaders here at Columbia
you've mentioned the solarization of the
outer atolls and I also saw you know the
spreading of the telecommunications
system and the reverse osmosis on the
northern outer atolls and I was
wondering what the marshalese
government's next goal is for technology
transfer to improve the quality of life
of marshes people in the urban and rural
areas and how could that be designed it
really builds on the traditional skills
and knowledge that exists on the islands
thank you thank you
I failed to mention that in addition to
civilization of homes our schools in the
outer islands also have solar as well as
these dispensaries the schools also
include of course lights and computer
plug-ins but the dispensaries include
refrigeration for drugs and
pharmaceuticals we are also working to
air on solar to grid for the district
centers of Metro & quarrelin
so we improve we're producing
electricity for 62 to 65 cents a
kilowatt and we're only able to charge
our people for the three max so the
government pairs put 20 cents of every
killer that is produced as subsidy if we
can do 20% maybe 800 kilowatts in nearby
and maybe one megawatt in in Majuro even
you can save up to 25% of the cost of
producing electricity in those
communities as well and it's cleaner and
also renewable and it does help to
winners of the petroleum habits but it
is a difficult question all of all of
our discussions about climate change
even now at the UN
must take into account the issue of
energy and how to produce it as you know
the islands are scattered or million
square miles of ocean we need also
diesel for ships and aviation fuel for
the airplane so these are these are
issues that will always haunt us as far
as government appropriations are
concerned but it's something that's on
the top of the president's list of
priorities and we continue to work to
find out in a place of generating energy
and water we have a 15 million dollar
grant for ebuy now going in to redo the
water distribution water making and
sewer system so that is as you know
we've devised is it's a very difficult
problem but we think that we've embarked
on a new beginning to make that a more
comfortable life as you call it to make
there's nothing wrong with having
running water there's nothing wrong with
having electricity that you can't afford
the people tend to try and put a cap on
on what electricity or water we we need
by what we actually use now but that
should not be the way to measure what
the true need should be thank you for
the question thank you yes my name is
Katrina sill and I'm a student at School
of International and public affairs as
well and my brother has been in the
Marshall Islands for the last six years
as a teacher I was also interested in
water systems can you speak more about
this subject specifically how it relates
to agriculture and how you plan to
implement these new water systems
60% told me we gotta probably part of
our policy is to require that 60% of all
funds that go out to to the outer
islands be used for food security and
where water and agricultural issues the
islands the adults have composed the
Marshall Islands collect drinking water
from the sky
that's all rainwater we have groundwater
and so in in some places but it is not
our quality that is good enough for
drinking except in a very very few spots
in the recent drought that affected the
northern Marshalls much of the
underwater underground water lines has
been inundated with salt and although it
just takes one or two king tides to in a
day it would take many years of of rain
to correct that that salt contamination
then affects the growth of of taro
grapefruit of citrus and and and other
food in the other islands so it is part
of our our priorities now to figure out
how to do a make up for that loss
because if we do not then it will also
affect the cash crops for the people and
they will have been to move out of where
they are now into other areas where they
will have access to good water as we
speak we are still distributing drinking
water in the northern rises from the
recent drought my name is Daniel Holt I
work with Professor Gerard at the center
of climate change law at law school much
of the world community seems to have
agreed on
on setting two degrees Celsius as the
goal for maximum temperature increase
with with climate change and my question
is whether two degrees is too much for
you and whether they're whether you have
in any way quantified the goals of what
your nation needs two degrees is what
they tell us is the limit above which we
cannot expect the average to survive
what is being predicted right now is
four degrees so if we don't figure out a
way of pulling that back to - all that
we're talking about in terms of
adaptation and mitigation in the small
island at all groups is for naught so we
struggle we still try to make sure in
our discussions today for example every
when we're talking about how to how to
push that back from from the four
percent four degrees that are vigorous
being predicted right now I guess to be
confirmed tomorrow by then latest report
IPCC which will still save four degrees
is what they're looking at if if you
have four degrees warming you your two
meters are already covered with water so
the at all countries are subject to the
kind of legal thinking that the
professor has been helping us with I
think we have time for one more question
I am Kumar deserves I'm student at
school of international public affairs
I can see in Marshall Islands strategic
plan for 2018 is
McCollum is planning to be a
self-sufficient country so what
government is thinking from being said
about being self-sufficient as its
depends highly on Oda and and I'd like
to specialize looking for how common
spends their Oda and their financial
budget but I see the on the website I
could find only budget till 2008 or 2009
it's not updated as small island groups
like the Marshalls kill bus and 12 can
be self-sufficient and can in fact
augment their what they earn on an
annual basis with trust funds that have
worked in the other in other areas but
in our case we're still struggling to
make sure that that produces a return so
that the government can be sustained
post 2043 but Oda is mostly used for the
purposes or any of these grants is
usually pre prescribed by the donor
country before it comes to the islands
themselves we have tried to concentrate
every of as of recent times on the
provision of affordable energy and
warning the two most touted resources
for the islands that people claim can in
fact form the basis for self-sufficiency
for this small islands is tuna and
tourism and you can have either without
energy and water so if we can solve that
problem have water that is affordable
and energy that can be turned into
including the processing and a value
adding
to the Torah we can in fact be be
self-sufficient we are also very
seriously and we've just been awarded a
grant to do a feasibility study for the
first commercial ocean thermal energy
conversion plant in the world and we are
going to pursue that because it gives us
those two it gives us energy and it
gives us water a renewable basis and
affordable basis but it also allows us
to provide for the development of of
fish and fish processing and and tourism
also it can at some point allow for the
production of hydrogen for export that
will make these traditional basket cases
economically in the Pacific if all goes
well net exporters of energy within our
lifetime and as these these these
platforms are seat our ocean base their
platforms that sit on the water they
will be a lot more resilient to climate
change there's something that you would
put on line so yes we are looking for
all means to be self-sufficient some of
them are exotic some some say over
ambitious but in the situation that we
are at right now
desperate desperate what is the elusive
rule professor
straits this frustrates call for
desperate measures
unfortunately we are at the stake he
stood for a while okay first thing my
name is Mariah Chan and I go to Barnard
and my question is very simple I mean I
was
wondering how the local attitude towards
this issue has developed as the severity
of the situation has seemed more
definitive and the reason I'm asking
that is because you know obviously the
severity of situation hasn't seemed to
fully saturate other nations very good
question and one of the most rewarding
part of this this mission in climate
change diplomacy in climate change
working climate change negotiations is
the involvement of our young people
because we've all we see this not as a
problem for you for us we're going to be
gone before the water comes but it's for
the next generation of the generation
after that for the children the
grandchildren great grandchildren and we
have a very good network of young people
working with government with NGOs with
the schools and the churches to bring
this matter to the to the community to
the home as an issue that we should all
be concerned about when we when we ask
our youngsters to turn the lights off to
to make sure that you you you you pick
up your trash don't throw plastic or
foam in the water this is all part of
our our attempt that and raising
awareness about the importance of
preparing yourself for climate change
and to deal with it and try and try and
do our own part to deal with it there's
also a very huge waste management issue
in all these small islands but a young
Marcus they give here and Tina have been
involved in the in the youth outreach
movement out in tomorrow's and they can
share this information which I think
it's very important part of the of our
climate change efforts to involve all
afraid of the society Thank You mr.
president and mr. Minister has been a
great honor and privilege to have you
with us today and to hear upfront what
your the challenges are as you know
many of us in different parts of
Columbia University of the Law School
the engineering school the Earth
Institute School of International and
public affairs many others who are
working on these issues of mitigation
and adaptation and we look forward to
working with you in the coming years to
try to address these very serious
problems thank you for coming and thank
you all